Ma che panino grande che hai
avevo solo 7 anni quando a scuola la
maestra Durante la ricreazione mi disse
che avevo portato un panino troppo
grande
quando sei una persona troppo sensibile
alcune parole te le porti dietro per
anni io da quel momento non portai più
la merenda a scuola
Sì lo so starete pensando e che
esagerata per una battuta prendersela
così tanto
Beh in realtà non funziona così Avete
presente il pongo ci avete mai giocato
il pongo è malleabile modellabile come
vogliamo e siamo noi a scegliere che
forma d'archi
lo stesso modo succede a noi quando
siamo piccole i commenti le relazioni le
cose che ci dicono gli altri quando
siamo piccoli ma anche gli abbracci le
parole d'amore non ricevute tutte queste
cose contribuiscono a definire la forma
del nostro pongo La nostra identità
a 12 anni iniziai a fare una dieta
perché mi vedevo le gambe grosse anche
se con la consapevolezza di oggi mi
rendo conto che non era così
iniziai a fare quelle solite diete che
troviamo online che ci dicono che in 10
giorni perderemo 10 kg Ecco Non fatele
ma rivolgetevi sempre degli esperti
perché sono dannose iniziai a fare
questa dieta e piano piano senza nemmeno
accorgermene stavo entrando nel circolo
vizioso del disturbo alimentare
sapete cos'è un disturbo alimentare
spesso si pensa che un disturbo
alimentare come dice la parola stessa
sia un problema strettamente collegato
con il cibo Beh sì in parte lo è ma
soffrire di un disturbo alimentare è
forse una tra le cose più difficili che
una persona possa trovarsi ad affrontare
vi spiego meglio
soffrire di un disturbo alimentare
significa vivere costantemente con una
vocina che tutto il giorno ti dice che
non vali niente che non sei abbastanza
che gli altri sono sempre migliori di te
ti ordina quello che devi e non devi
mangiare e poi ti fa venire i sensi di
colpa e ti dice di andare a correre a
correre per bruciare calorie
ma non è finita qui quella vocina poi ti
chiede sempre di più di più e dico e ti
costringe ad isolarti e a rimanere con
lei perché tanto non puoi stare con le
altre persone perché tu non sei
all'altezza e non vali niente ma non è
finita qui un disturbo alimentare
definisce anche il tuo umore
passi dall'essere felice poche volte
all'essere triste all'improvviso ma non
è finita qui quella vocina interna mi
diceva che a scuola dovevo essere la più
brava a casa dovevo essere la figlia
perfetta e agli occhi degli altri dovevo
risultare sempre sicura di me stessa
a 18 anni
arrivarono poi 18 anni e vi starete
chiedendo Ma dai 12 ai 18 anni cosa è
successo
è il periodo dell'adolescenza un
ragazzo una ragazza dovrebbe uscire
divertirsi uscire con gli amici andare
in discoteca
Beh in realtà io la mia adolescenza non
l'ho vissuta
a 18 anni è stato il momento in cui io
toccai il fondo come un giorno presi
tante pasticche e tenta il suicidio
perché si deve arrivare a farci così
male e a toccare il fondo per far vedere
agli altri che si stiamo
io durante gli anni della mia malattia
sono sempre stata normopeso come mi
vedete adesso e gli altri facevano
fatica a comprendere a riconoscere il
mio Il dolore perché spesso si pensa che
soffrire un disturbo alimentare
significhi essere per forza sottopeso o
in sovrappeso ma in realtà non è sempre
così
e spesso tendiamo a giudicare il dolore
delle altre persone in base a quello che
vediamo dall'esterno esteriormente
dimenticandoci però che il dolore di
ognuno di noi ha una forma diversa
Quando feci quel gesto estremo mi
ricoverarono in ospedale e da quel
momento capi tre cose
la prima non bisogna aspettare gli altri
che si accorgono del nostro dolore per
cambiare le cose gli altri appunto
perché altri rispetto a noi non possono
comprendere fino in fondo quello che
proviamo e come ci sentiamo
spesso aspettiamo che arrivi qualcuno a
salvarci
dimenticandoci invece del grande potere
interiore che abbiamo dentro di noi
la seconda cosa che capì è che tutto
Quell'amore che continuamente
ricerchiamo all'esterno siamo noi per
primi che bisogna darcelo e bisogna
scavare scavare e scavare per ritrovarlo
ma è dentro di noi c'è ed esiste
infine la terza cosa che capì è che le
nostre emozioni non vanno ignorate
come quando ci facciamo male ad un
braccio o ad una gamba e andiamo dal
dottore e chiediamo aiuto lo stesso
dovremmo fare con la nostra salute
mentale
spesso però quello che avviene è che noi
siamo portati ad allontanarci e a
cercare di scappare da quelle emozioni
soprattutto da quelle negative
Ecco Oggi vorrei insieme a voi che
iniziassimo a dare un nuovo nome a
quelle emozioni a chiamarle intense
Sfidanti
impegnative e capire che sono proprio
quelle che ci permettono di apportare un
cambiamento nella nostra vita e capire
che sono qui non per un caso
ma per farci evolvere
un'altra cosa che bisogna capire è che
ogni emozione contiene al suo interno un
messaggio un dato e non bisogna
ignorarlo le emozioni è qui Per farci
capire che c'è qualcosa dentro di noi
che deve essere cambiato su cui bisogna
lavorare ma bisogna essere disposti a
starci nel dolore
perché l'unico modo per uscirne è
passarci attraverso
come è fatta a guarire e ad essere così
forte mi chiedono ad oggi
perché non avevo altra scelta se volevo
vivere non mi sono mai arresa perché
sapevo dentro di me che potevo stare
meglio
non possiamo pretendere che le cose
cambino se continuiamo a fare le stesse
cose e per poter cambiare la nostra vita
bisogna essere disposti a staccarci
dallo scoglio
conoscete l'ideale dell'ostrica di
Giovanni Verga e sapete come nascono le
perle
le perle nascono perché un corpo
estraneo entra al loro interno
all'interno del mollusco il mollusco
inizia a generare una reazione e a
secernere una sostanza cristallina che
prende il nome di madreperla E finché
questo corpo estraneo rimane all'interno
del corpo del mollusco continua a creare
questa sostanza per dare origine a un
oggetto duro e lucente La Perla
quindi un'ostrica Integra che non ha mai
avuto un problema e non ha mai subito
un'intrusione da parte di un corpo
estraneo non potrà mai generare una
perla
e metaforicamente è quello che succede a
noi dal nostro dolore e dalla nostra
sofferenza si nasconde un grande
potenziale e sono le esperienze più
difficili più traumatiche più pesanti a
smuovere qualcosa dentro di noi e Ria
offrirci l'occasione di cambiare e di
trasformarci
Ecco Oggi vorrei capovolgere lo sguardo
a farvi capire che sono i momenti più
difficili a darvi l'opportunità di
evolvere a farvi capire che è proprio
nei momenti di difficoltà che non sono
qui
per la fine ma per dimostrarci che c'è
un inizio
a farvi capire e a farvi trovare il
vostro coraggio
per staccarvi da quello scoglio perché
finché rimanete attaccati lì e non avete
il coraggio di andare in quel mare
aperto di attraversarlo quel mare non
potrete mai generare la vostra Perla
chi sono oggi
una volta se mi avessero fatto questa
domanda avrei risposto
Giorgia è una persona bulimica
e non saprei non avrei potuto dire
nient'altro
il mio pongo aveva una consistenza molto
fragile
oggi le cose sono cambiate e se mi fanno
la domanda Chi è Giorgia rispondo
diversamente
ho lavorato anni per ridare forza a quel
pongo
sono Giorgia Bellini Ho 25 anni Sono una
life coach facilitatrice di mindfulness
e sono autrice del libro Nathan volte
tradotto anche in lingua inglese
ora Voglio condividere con voi una frase
di Sant'Agostino che è bellissima che
racchiude un po' quello che ci siamo
detti oggi
non uscire fuori rientra in te stesso
e nell'interiorità dell'uomo che abita
la verità
ma non è finita qui una delle cose più
belle che ho creato ad oggi è una
community online dove racconto a ragazze
e ragazzi e a qualsiasi persona perché
un disturbo alimentare può colpire
chiunque che non disturba alimentare Si
può guarire
e in questo momento sto realizzando un
servizio per aiutare le persone che
soffre i disturbi alimentari a cambiare
la loro vita
e voglio farvi vedere alcuni dei
messaggi che mi scrivono ogni giorno e
di mostrarvi l'importanza
che c'è per far sentire meno soli le
altre persone
mi piace credere che le persone che
hanno superato dei momenti difficili
debbano a loro volta piantare un seme di
speranza per chi in questo momento si
sente solo e lotta con se stesso
Spero oggi attraverso la mia
testimonianza di farvi trovare il
coraggio di staccarvi da quello scoglio
e di generare la vostra Perla e comunque
il panino Ora è veramente buono